IS USING A GAS STOVE THAT
SURFACED ONLINE IT WAS A
REACTION LOUISIANA SINNER'S SIN
KENNEDY I'M NOT GIVING UP MY GA
STOVE I WAS ACTUALLY A COOK IN
RESTAURANT WHEN I WAS YOUNGER
AND THAT YOU CAN'T COOK AT A
RESTAURANT WITHOUT A GAS STOVE.
FAMOUSLY, PRESIDENT LINCOLN HAD
A TEAM OF BROTHELS.
SOMETIMES I THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS A TEAM OF MORONS.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE UNFAIR.
THAT'S FAIR.
>> MEN THE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
APPOINTEES ARE VERY SMART.
BUT SO WAS THE UNABOMBER.
MY POINT IS THAT THEY MAY BE
SMART BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
SENSE.
FOR EXAMPLE.
SECRETARY OF BUDDHA GENIC WERE
GOING THIS WEEK TOOK A CARBON
SPEWING PROFIT PLANE TO NEW YOR
CITY FOR A FEW HOURS TO DO A
RADIO INTERVIEW.
I LIKE THE SECRETARY.
BUT LESS THAN 30 DAYS AGO, HIS
DEPARTMENT TOLD THE STATES THAT
THEY OUGHT TO MAKE BUILDING NEW
ROADS THE MOST POSSIBLE PRICE
ORDER BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
NOT EVERYBODY HAS A PRIVATE JET.
MOST PEOPLE LEAVE THE DRIVER CAR
.
AND I KNOW LIFE IS FORM OF
CONTRADICTIONS BUT FROM WHERE I
COME FROM WITH A HOCK WE CALL
THAT HYPOCRISY.
I WORK UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
THE SECRETARY AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE A BRAVE
ECO- WARRIOR, YOU NEED TO BE
CONSISTENT.
THE BAND, I WAS GONNA SAY SEAN,
YOU MENTION THE BAN ON GAS
STOVES BY PRESIDENT BIDEN.
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER THE
CONTEXT OF MUCH OF THE DECISION
MADE.
SOMETHING IS VERY WRONG AND OUR
COUNTRY AND MOST AMERICANS KNOW
IT.
THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN.
CRIME IS WAY UP IN NATIONAL DEB
IS GREATER THEN THE NATIONAL
OUTPUT.
IF INFLATION KEEPS GOING UP, TH
THE POWERBALL JACKPOT WILL BE
HAPPY HAD OF HAMBURGER.
70 PERCENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE THE COUNTRY IS HEADE
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
WORRIED ABOUT GAS STOVES?
THIS IS THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATED A
BLIND SPOT.
ABOUT THE LIVES AND CONCERNS OF
M1 MARINADE CHIMERIC MEN
AMERICANS.
IF I WERE PRESIDENT AND MY
NUMBER MY ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS A
DECLINE IN THE STANDARD OF
LIVING FOR MOST AMERICANS, I
WOULD NOT WORRIED ABOUT GAS
STOVES.
>> ALSO IF YOU DON'T HEARD ABOU
THIS AND WHEN TO GET UP RID OF
FLUORESCENT LIGHT BULBS.
I LIKE MY FLUORESCENT LIGHT
BULBS LIKE A MY GAS STOVES.
I LIKE TO KEEP IT.
IF THEY BAN IT, WHO GONNA PAY
FOR ALL THE IS STOVES FOR PEOPL
THAT CAMP AFFORD THEM?
>> LET ME MAKE MORE MORE PLAYED
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
STOP LISTENING TO THE BERSERK
WING OF YOUR PARTY.
WORRY ABOUT AND TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
MOMS AND DADS OREO ABOUT.
WHEN THEY LIE DOWN TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT AND CAN'T.
IN THE REST OF IT WILL TAKE CAR
OF ITSELF.
>> I THINK YOU